okay so coyote alright and I am going to
do a yield here you see that I do the
yield inside of it and keep it outside
five keep him out
[Music]
hold him cut him this is going to be 0
I'm going to heal and I just keep them
outside in this hand go back this hasn't
moving here but it kinda move don't move
in here that's gonna be wait whoa
[Music]
the moves so simple it looks like other
stuff this is where the technical
deviation comes in okay so you you think
you what you're doing is you're shoving
him down with that hand that's like
so I'm just changing the geometry but
that's it and now there's going to be an
in space in here see I'm actually
holding them up and so what I'm going to
do is instead of push him down I take
this out of the way so not here and pull
tight you see that people let go to use
the grip then when I crank this angle
you see the tilt of the spine all right
then I'm holding it as long as I stay
here at the entire time he'll stay here
the entire time putting foot back where
I was
did you why'd you move your foot out why
did you quit out someone he's trying to
put his face is poured out out back from
his line of gravity
you see that okay so here here we are we
can hang out here all the time
and that little tension but once I take
this away do you see how it gets the
whole generator so I take the whole
you'll feel it boom there's that tension
then I take it away take away the
tension it's not him falling into this
and it goes you get the person leaning
on you little bit we're leaving on we
can hang out here just you sound
exaggerated by status zero pressure and
then I take away the tension this is
very soft
so a little bit more full the host here
should it should be the same in it
oh there's that angle you see there's an
angle disappear
no don't come back over this boom is
almost like out tilt he's holding on to
me now
that's what's all in there see
hold on you and then I take away this
list when I keep pulling on it you can
give him his face take it away take it
away take it away
I'm not going down with you
you're gonna clear the harm don't cut
down I think if I if I try to do the
other way see he's got a good grip see
normally you do good when you use two
hands right normally when you do grip
fighting you guys know how to punch you
this guy's allowed to punch me okay so
this is the point of contention and my
job is to deconstruct this situation so
the skin step in here are you leave
Islam there and I'm gonna stand here and
instead of him being here I can move in
just like that
that's all I need then put me there
right and now he's holding on to me you
see that he's old like me then I cannot
use it so all the exaggerated without
the neutering hey you can you feel that
so okay so now all I have to do is take
away that ledge you see you get it and
you can take away that ledge that dorky
way or you're gonna just keep moving it
over here what do you feel getting less
and less it's getting less and less and
one exaggerated it's getting less and
less and less and less and less and less
fun okay what you're doing doesn't work
worse says he he thinks he's to push to
hold on right and I remember when I was
training there would be some Nagas
wiggle and then they get mad at you you
don't go right well you you've knocked
the head off so I just operate inside
the grip that's when it's teaching me up
right inside the grip then classic Jiu
Jitsu now he's using me to support him
and I go like that now I'm fighting him
what I want to do is heal to that spa
heal to that spa okay we're just doing
it in the technique boom boom
[Music]
I still have the ham hey I'm not putting
down